hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his essay
concrete approaches to investigating the
ontological mystery Gabriele Marcel
provides us with a number of examples of
what he terms mysteries and he wants to
distinguish these sorts of mysteries
from anything that somebody thinking
about theological mysteries of say the
Incarnation you know in Christianity
would have but also from another sense
of mystery where it's just some some
problem to be solved as a matter of fact
he stresses that a mystery is something
fundamentally different from a problem
and there are a number of different ways
in which they vary a mystery is
something deeper than a problem
it involves us with something more
something meta problematical in meaning
something that not only reflects upon
the problem but goes beyond it that
transcends it in some way it also
involves us as being part of the problem
in some way so we can't get out of it we
can't extricate ourselves from it and
the orientation that we take may in fact
have very important implications for how
well we're able to grasp the mystery at
all
or as such so he talks about the
ontological mystery that's in the title
of this very piece and he never comes
right out and says here's my definition
of the ontological mystery because
mysteries aren't the sort of thing that
you can define in any case but this one
is in a certain respect the you could
say if a mystery is a meta problem this
is the meta mystery this is the mystery
that in a certain sense encompasses and
involves all the other ones and it has
to do not with whether there is being
but what being is we have as Marcel says
an ontological need or exigency we have
a need for being we have a need for
something that goes beyond what we can
categorize what we can tally up what we
can put together in a system well we
might be able to put into an algorithm
or some computer platform or program we
have a need for something more and there
is something more now
that mystery we're not going to delve
into too much as an example let's look
instead at some of the other things that
he calls mysteries because those reflect
on the mystery of being and perhaps help
us to understand it they certainly are
brought up in that way in this this
essay so one that he talks about early
on is the mystery of knowledge he tells
us that it's a mistake to take
epistemology as first philosophy because
knowledge itself is within being so it's
not as if knowledge yields us what could
be being which is a very common tendency
in modern philosophy and even in some
some earlier philosophy as well but
particularly in modern philosophy and we
can substitute for that language if we
want it as well
knowledge is something that we have a
hard time formulating knowledge about in
a way that actually
we're able to come up with all sorts of
cool theories of what knowledge is but
most of them aren't able to
satisfactorily address themselves let
alone the beings that are supposed to be
using those theories to make sense out
of anything and Marcel says really
knowledge is itself a mystery and it's
something that requires us to engage in
uses this term participation says
knowledge derives from a mode of
participation of participation in being
that no theory of knowledge can account
for because the theory itself
presupposes this participation that
doesn't mean that we can't learn
anything about it or grasp anything
about it or penetrate into knowledge or
acquire knowledge about knowledge but we
do so with it as a mystery not a problem
or a set of problems he then talks about
another very important thing that comes
up not only in modern philosophy but
also in ancient and medieval philosophy
how are these things if they're in
things indeed body and soul mind spirit
whatever you want to call it how are
they actually a union because that's
what I do experience
I don't experience myself as merely
wetware you know brain connections or
anything like that and circulatory
systems I experience myself in my body
as my body but as more than my body so
he says there is a mystery of the union
of one's body in mind the indivisible
unity that has never quite adequately
expressed my phrases such as I have a
body I use my body I feel my body its
exterior - any kind of analysis and can
in no way he says be reconstituted by
any synthesis that begins with logically
prior elements the indivisible unity of
body and soul is not only given
something that we have right it's given
we experience it he says I will even say
it is giving in the sense of what I will
call the presence of me to myself a
present
inadequately symbolized by the act of
self-consciousness the union of the body
and soul provides us with another
example of a mystery a mystery that
bears upon the very nature of our
humanity and indeed what else might be
related to us but not quite the same as
us for example in AI he goes on then to
talk about the mystery of evil and he
says it's a mistake to view it as the
problem of evil as so many people in
philosophy have done and so you know if
we want to say well what is this problem
why is there evil in a world why why do
we have to experience the suffering that
we do why are things as screwed up as
they are he says I am inevitably
inclined to treat the problem of evil as
a disorder I contemplate whose causes
reasons for being or hidden purpose I
attempt to sort out how is it that this
machine whether it be this machine here
in the body or the mechanism of the
entire world system how does it function
in a defective manner or is it perhaps
the apparent flaws do this time - a real
defect in my perception the real
disorder is in me but it remains
objective for my thought that discovers
and studies it and then he says here's
the key point
evil that's only stated or observed is
no longer the evil that has suffered it
really ceases to be evil we're no longer
grasping what it was that we were
attempting to make sense out of a
mystery encompasses the thing that it's
attempting to make sense out of and
Marcel says that the key to
understanding this is the fact that I am
involved I can't step back and say why
did God create such a world was he not
powerful enough or you know take out God
and say why can't you manatee and make
it into this into a paradise right I
have to deal with the fact that in
asking these questions
I've already contributed in some respect
I haven't involved in the breakdowns and
the things going wrong and
badness within the world he says I only
perceive evil to the extent that it
touches me that is to say to the extent
in which I am involved in the sense of
being implicated in the affair he says
the distinction between what is within
me and what would be merely in front of
me breaks down under the power of a
second order reflection and another
mystery that he talks but at that point
just it very briefly is that of love
later on he will talk about love in
terms of charity Caritas right but he's
he's not really using that term too much
there instead he talks about a key Marx
alien concept that of availability being
there for another discipline to be they
say in French being at the disposal of
another who needs us that is part of
what it means to love that cannot be
understood in terms of some set of rules
although that doesn't mean that there
aren't rules just that the rules don't
encompass at all and it's something that
we have to live out and explore and is
never exhausted in in so far as we're
actually living it out even after people
die we can continue to love them and
that's kind of a mystery itself as we're
going to talk about he goes on and he
talks about another thing that is really
quite interesting which we could call
the mystery of encounter so he says
here's a particular example
you may have an encounter that is deep
and lasting albeit indeterminate effect
on your life everyone can have had the
experience of what such an encounter can
mean from the spiritual point of view
but philosophers typically ignore this
or disdain this why because it affects
only the individual as a person it's not
universe I universal izybelle
it does not concern thinking beings in
general and yet this is absolutely
central for our lives as human persons
this is
something that literature and even
history will will engage with drama does
this as well so to the fine arts so he
says it's evident that such encounters
present if you will a problem but the
solution to the problem falls short of
the only question that matters if
someone says to me you met that person
at a certain place because he or she
likes the same kind of countryside as
you or his health requires that he or
she received the same treatments one
sees right away the explanation is not
there that's not where you should be
looking how did that person come to
matter to me how did I wind up being
engaged with that person and he says I
find myself in the presence of a mystery
a miss that is to say a reality whose
roots go far beyond what is properly
speaking the problematical will we avoid
the difficulty by saying there's nothing
here except a question of fortunate
coincidence or good luck I know from
within myself there's a strong protest
against this hollow phase this
ineffectual negation of something I
sense at the very center of myself he
says I who inquire about the meaning and
conditions of possibility of this
encounter cannot place myself outside or
opposite I am engaged in this encounter
I depend on it I am in some way interior
to it envelops and comprehends me even
if I don't comprehend it it has changed
me but the change hasn't been some mere
exterior force impinging upon me it is
called out of myself things by which I
have changed myself now think about
every important relationship that you
have had whether with a mentor or
somebody who you learned from whether it
was a friend whether it was a rival who
somehow brought out something important
from you whether it was an author who
somehow you encountered and engaged
through their texts there's a mystery
there something that Marcel says goes
beyond the realm of the problematic he
also talks about a little bit later
death what do we make of death
he tells us that those who you know we
we love after they they have died do
they exist in any way whatsoever he
tells us well that's actually a mystery
do they have any presence do they live
on in our memories what does that mean
to live on and in a memory are the
living in the dead in any way connected
with each other
this is a fundamental existential
question if we conceive of death merely
in the sense of a function and ceasing
of a function really then there's
there's no question at all no of course
not there's no it's all in your head but
perhaps that's not all that's going on
another thing that he talks about is the
mystery of hope and Marcel spends a lot
of time unpacking what genuine hope
would look like as opposed to mere
pollyannish you know looking on the
bright side of life or anything along
those lines and you know he tells us
that genuine hope hope in the heart of
the one it inhabits and the judgments
cast upon it by someone who remains a
prisoner of objectivity genuine hope
can't be understood by some sort of
person like that because it straddles
the border between pure problems and
pure mystery he tells us that what hope
is he says to hope against all hope that
the person who I love will recover from
an illness that is devouring her and
which is considered to be incurable as
to say it is not possible that I am
alone in willing her recovery it is
impossible that reality and its very
depths as hospital only undifferenced to
what I declare to be a good in itself a
little later he gives you another really
wonderful characterization of hope as
thinking that there is something there
that will cooperate with you
being if it is what is ought to be now
you can frame that in terms of a problem
but what we're talking about there
really involves the very core of a human
being this is a mystery
it's affirming something meta
problematical something going beyond the
realm of the problems and the techniques
that can be used to resolve them one
last one that he mentions in there as
well is the meaning of the valley or the
mystery of the value of life and here we
have you know the typical philosophical
question right everybody shows up to
philosophy 101 or they hear that you're
a philosophy professor and they say oh
hey what's the meaning of life right as
if it's something that you could just
well it's 42 or it's have a lot of fun
or you know serve God or pick something
like that something that you could
encapsulate in a nice slogan if life was
just a problem yes you could do that or
perhaps it might be more complicated you
need a whole manual with lots and lots
of cases but it could be then just
turned into a set of you know procedures
to follow that's not the way life
actually works the question of the value
or the meaning of life in general and
one's own life is a Marcel Yin mystery
it is something that involves us the
very stance that we take the very
choices that we make the experiences
that we undergo the interpretation of
that experience on our part will will
inevitably color the question itself in
such a way that might keep some of us
from ever getting an answer but might
open up the possibility for greater
answers to to many of us and we might
not even like the answer we might have
to struggle with the mystery that the
answer seems to be imposing upon us so
hopefully by looking at each of these we
see that they have these these traits in
common of being meta problematical of
involving us as subjects
in you know connecting us to something
that goes beyond us and the realm of our
knowledge or our problem
problematization of these matters and
ultimately connects us with the mystery
of being something that Marcel thinks
that we have whether we realize it or
not a fundamental need or exigency or
demand for at the center of our own
being these mysteries are ways in which
we live out these particular modes you
might say of the fundamental problem but
each of them matters in its own right as
well and they all to some degree connect
up with each other if we look at them
closely and long and you might say
generously enough